es ist wirklich etwas ganz erstaunliches
passiert in den vergangenen tagen eine
kreml nahe russische zeitung hat das
komplett überwachungsprotokolle wallis
veröffentlicht dass während seiner reise
durch sibirien angefertigt wurde
er war ja in tomsk unten in nowosibirsk
unterwegs die vergangenen tage vor
seiner vergiftung und hat dort andere
oppositionelle getroffen hat sich dort
mit seinen verbündeten getroffen war
baden war einkaufen war essen und in
diesem überwachungsprotokolle steht das
alles drin
die wissen mit welcher kreditkarte er
bezahlt hat wo er sushi gegessen hat und
wo er baden war und mit welchen freunden
er unterwegs war und die frage ist
natürlich warum wird das ausgerechnet
jetzt veröffentlicht spektakuläres
dokumente wenn es denn echte es ist es
echt es sieht alles danach aus dass es
echt ist die sprecherin von nav allen
die das team von navalny haben das mehr
oder weniger bestätigt die haben sich
nicht überrascht gezeigt vom ausmaß der
überwachung waren aber doch überrascht
dass das plötzlich so öffentlich gemacht
wird denn wenn in russland so etwas
öffentlich wird dann natürlich weil es
öffentlich gemacht werden soll und es
wird vermutet natürlich warum das jetzt
veröffentlicht werden könnte
die antwort ist wahrscheinlich die der
kreml möchte sagen na ja wir haben ihn
ja überwacht warum hätten wir ihn
umbringen sollen wir hatten ja alles
unter kontrolle das ist wahrscheinlich
dass bin mit dem hier gearbeitet wird
du kennst die frau von navalny hast sie
getroffen wie schätzt du sie ein wie
hast du sie erlebt ich habe aber nie
interviewt die frau habe ich nicht
getroffen ich kenne mehrere personen aus
dem team die natürlich immer wieder auch
über die mit dem ich über die frau
sprechen konnte sie rückt jetzt
natürlich wieder einmal in den fokus
sowie das bislang immer wahr wenn ihr
mann verhaftet wurde wenn ihr mann
angegriffen wurde
obwohl sie das eigentlich überhaupt
nicht möchte sie steht felsenfest hinter
ihrem mann sie ist eine wahnsinnig
tapfere frau die sich über all die jahre
dran gewöhnen musste dass ihr mann in
ständiger lebensgefahr schwebt und im
prinzip auch sie selbst natürlich nicht
sicher ist und man hat glaube ich im
letzten tag in omsk auch gesehen was für
eine kraft sie hat dass sie dass sie die
ganzen schikanen der russischen ärzte
und behörden mitgemacht hat und dann
eben diesen knallharten brief an putin
geschrieben hat also dass es wirklich
eine wahnsinnig starke persönlichkeit
europa ist schockiert von diesem
giftanschlag von diesem mordversuch auf
navalny wie sind denn die reaktion wie
fallen sie aus in russland bei den
menschen ja also wenn die russen 1 nicht
sind dann schockiert darüber dass ein
oppositioneller vergiftet wurde
das muss man sagen ist mittlerweile gute
alte russische tradition das so fallen
auch die die reaktion aus niemand in der
opposition ist überrascht dass jetzt
navalny vergiftet wurde
die haben alle noch bestens im kopf was
vor einigen jahren was 2015 mit boris
nemzow auf einem der damaligen
oppositionsführer passiert ist dieser
mann wurde auch überwacht vom fsb und
wurde in wenigen hundert metern
entfernung vom kreml auf offener straße
erschossen
und zufälligerweise stand ein müllwagen
gerade vor der überwachungskamera also
wenn die menschen in russland 1 nicht
schockiert dass es den oppositionellen
an den kragen geht auch wenn es
natürlich jedes mal erschreckend ist
dass es passiert und dass einem auch
zeigt wie machtlos mann ist gegen dieses
regime aber müsse das nicht gerade dazu
führen diese regelmäßigkeit und dieses
symbol dafür dass dieses system putin
einfach menschen aus schaltet das die
menschen aufstehen gegen putin im land
aus stehen ähnlich wie in weißrussland
wo zugleich kommt ja diese frage warum
das nicht schon längst passiert ist dass
die stellt man sich seit vielen jahren
navalny war der erste der es wieder
geschafft hat massen demonstrationen zu
organisieren und auf die straßen zu
bringen
ansonsten muss man sagen dass die
russische diktatur einfach besser
funktioniert als die diktatur in
weißrussland oder früher in der ukraine
navalny wurde nie zu einer wirklichen
figur gemacht die landesweit bekannt ist
ja er hat eine gewisse bekanntheit dies
relativ hoch für ein
oppositionspolitiker aber in den
hauptnachrichten
das des staatsfernsehens kommt er
überhaupt nicht vor und sehr viele
menschen schauen diese nachrichtensender
immer noch gut hin zum beispiel hat sich
jahrelang wirklich davor gedrückt auch
nur den namen in den mund zu nehmen
immer wenn er darauf angesprochen wurde
hat er geschummelt hat gesagt ja dieser
mann oder hat ganz allgemein gesprochen
also man hat wirklich versucht derweil
nicht klein zu halten um ihm keine bühne
zu bieten und jetzt muss man auch nicht
darüber berichten also ich habe in den
hauptnachrichten des russischen
staatsfernsehens keine meldungen darüber
gesehen was mittlerweile nie passiert